make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with Justice League
Odyssey this is interesting
Justice League Odyssey is a very very
intriguing story just because it's it's
again like the first Iraq my rule when
it comes to new comics is I'll give it
like probably one or two story arcs to
kind of see how I feel about it
and when it comes to Justice League
Odyssey it's interesting because like
there's on one side of the equation a
lot could come out of this but on the
other side of the equation pretty much
nothing could come out of this it's got
my interest piqued of course written by
Joshua Williamson so no wonder why I
like it but what this does is this
initially kind of picks up with Jessica
Cruz now in a lot of ways this is DC's
expansion of the Justice League mythos
and those of you guys who were reading
DC Comics post-crisis which I don't know
how many of you guys are old enough to
basically have started picking up comics
in 1984 or eight 1986 to start reading
forward if you have awesome you're one
of the few but the idea is at
post-crisis DC only had like the Justice
League International right like it was
just kind of a hodgepodge of what in a
lot of ways were the unsalables people
who just could not really hold their own
comic in DC just kind of tacked Justice
League on to the name and threw them all
under one team and it actually proved to
be resoundingly successful there was a
really really smart move by DC and so
what they did is they started branching
out so you had like extreme justice and
different things like that this is very
similar to that DC is really kind of
taking a more gradual approach to it but
it's very similar to that you have
Justice League Odyssey now you've got
the return of Justice League dark and
then you've got Justice League proper
but with Odyssey that's really kind of
focuses on like a space based Justice
League team and so picking up with
Jessica Cruz again she's basically at
the at the outer fringes of what's
called the ghost sector and what's
basically told to us here by Joshua
Williamson is that after the events of
Justice League no justice if you guys
remember during that story
one of the first worlds to be attacked
was a world called color and that was
basically home to the race of people
that Brainiac comes from and so where
that world was saved essentially like
all these different worlds and it kind
of been bottled up we're effectively
like released out there into the
universe but then in turn we find out
during this story that they've all kind
of been cordoned off and so basically
what the guardians of the universe did
after the world to release is they were
quarantine and what you have is this
giant storm Maelstrom that essentially
like surrounds the ghost sector those
who try to pass through usually end up
getting destroyed and those who are
inside can never really escape so it's
kind of an interesting scenario because
what you end up having here is Jessica
Cruz who's kind of like the lone sensory
really kind of lady the only green only
Green Lantern from the Justice League
who's able to basically serve around as
a kind of century for the four they go
sector whose also being watched by a guy
now that guy who's watching her is
exceedingly important and I didn't catch
that the first time around but when this
happens what you end up getting is
basically like a ship of Brainiac
being piloted by cyborg that's just like
careening into the ghost sector it
literally comes out of nowhere but this
little Justice League team is composed
of Starfire as Rio and cyborg and so
it's interesting because with these with
these guys kind of banding together we
don't know exactly why they're here at
least we're not told initially while
we're here instead you literally have
Jessica Cruz just like are you guys out
of your mind I supposed to be here and
of course they make their way through
the Maelstrom and just end up like crash
landing on on a planet now once they're
stuck here that's where we kind of start
getting a bit of an explanation on
what's going on that is simply what's
happened here is that somewhere along
the line they've all each felt a kind of
tug when it came to cyborg his mother
box sort of Pingdom but it was more of
like a pool like hey you have to go
check that out that's basically what it
was and then with Starfire it was the
same way and Azrael it was the same way
and the question was why like what
pulled these guys here and what we
basically end up getting is the return
of Darkseid the guy who is basically
watching Jessica Cruz when she was
flying outside and basically sort of
like follow the trail of psy boring
company through the Maelstrom and onto
this world now the reason why he looks
this way this is a very important thing
that I want to talk about the reason why
he looks this way is the progression of
Darkseid so during the events of Justice
League dark side war and we never really
got to see what the intention of Jeff
Jones was with it because basically as
soon as Darkseid war ended we went right
into DC rebirth but during Darkseid war
we basically had the anti-monitor versus
dark side and dark side was basically
like killed and set on fire and like all
these crazy things but was reborn as a
baby and then taken in by his daughter
Grail and so for a little while for like
actually for more than a little while in
DC we had no idea what happened like all
we knew was that like in DC universe
rebirth number one it was like okay so
Grails got baby Darkseid and then we
never really found out what happened it
wasn't really until after Greg Rucka is
like whole run on Wonder Woman ended and
then things were taken over that
basically like we ended up having a
having baby Darkseid being taken by
Grail and literally like killing off
like Olympian gods right like healed off
Hercules absorbed his energy became a
teenager and then killed Zeus absorb his
energy and the return to his current
form but at the moment we don't really
know exactly why he's here and it's kind
of a funny thing because what he
basically says is like you guys are
destined to be the new gods of the
multiverse of course a fight breaks out
between Darkseid and like you know the
Justice League Odyssey like you know we
had we kind of had to see them fight
like it's kind of what it is like Joshua
was like hey look you guys probably want
to see them fight so like here you go
and it's kind of a cool thing but it's
also designed a kind of show where
Darkseid resides in the greater scheme
of things at least in relation to these
guys and really like none of them really
stand much of a chance here I mean
they're all kind of getting rekt where
the fight sort of makes its way towards
a temple only for us to find out that
this temple is basically giving worship
to starfire herself and it's kind of
intriguing because witness going on this
is one of the things there's one big
question that Williamson doesn't really
seem to answer here but he also kind of
leaves it to the story of the of the
Justice League no justice you kind of
tell us that but what's going on here is
basically like there's a handful of
people who are praising Starfire and who
view her as their goddess now most of
the worshipers here are basically been
killed we're not gonna find out who
killed him for a little while but like
Starfire showing up here a meeting like
the loss of the priest one of the only
people who seems to have survived she's
kind of given an explanation of like we
see you as our goddess we knew it was
only a matter of time before you were
gonna come back and save us so like are
you here to basically you know reward us
for our due diligence
she's viewed as a god and Starfire
herself isn't really even used to that
she's kinda like um I mean you know like
I guess but like I'm not really a
goddess but one of the little known
powers of Starfire has but you don't
really see her use all that often is the
ability to kind of absorb language into
herself you know almost kind of absorb
of a piece of a person into herself and
kind of helping this priest pass and
then you basically like absorb the
language so she can read the hieroglyphs
she also absorbs a piece of the priest
into herself now again like when that
happens she's kind of infected but
joshua williamson leaves a lot of things
ambiguous in terms of what's going on
it's just like her powers kind of start
freaking out every buddy panic she's
like okay we got to get her to her home
planet of Tamra now remember Tamra was
one of the planets that was confined
really by like Brainiac and the collar
winds and so on and so forth so her
planets still there and it's actually
here inside to go sector and so now it's
matter of hey like we have to find a way
out but if we can't then we have to get
to her planet in order to basically find
some way to basically save her to keep
her alive or something along those lines
but once they leave and then fly
somewhere else into the ghost sector
they kind of land on like this derelict
world like this kind of frozen world and
they're basically met with what looks to
be kind of like a bandit a source now of
course this guy basically says hey look
I'm a medic on my homeworld I'm here to
basically heal you and I'm here to
provide you with assistance and so on
and I can basically heal Starfire so it
wraps up pretty quick in terms of like
Starfire being you know fill with a
plague as basically what he says is hey
there's a plague that kind of ravaged
across the ghost sector and that's why
she's sick and so when I said
gets wrapped up pretty quickly but what
we end up finding out is this group that
cyborg and company run into this group
they meet hates them too like this
technological city of sort and what we
end up finding out is this is a world
that worships cyborgs and so they'd so
like their whole argument is one we
don't know if you're legit and - in
order to find out we kind of have to
test you which is kind of interesting
because they basically end up like
making them fight in a kind of
tournament of sorts but what they're
looking for is a particular set of
events to unfold they're looking for
cyborgs to basically modify his body and
then in turn like take out some force
but that's the whole idea behind it is
the machine could basically adapt to
almost anything the machine could modify
itself in by virtue of like its power
overcome the Challenger like overcome as
real and it is kind of interesting here
because there's a religious theme behind
it and we'll find out here in a second
like there's actually a reason why
Azrael in particular was chosen to be
the guy that he's gonna face off against
but when that happens and he proves to
be victorious then he's in turn shown to
be like the Mishima they're kind of like
okay we believe in your power we believe
in what you're capable of and who you
truly are we follow your path now and so
again like without happening what we end
up finding out is that there's a kind of
insurrectionist that exists on this
planet and this insurrection is follows
in the path of Azrael this guy calls
himself like rapture as a being who
basically swears and says like the
machine is not an actual God as though
it was really like it's much a
ceremonial set of circumstances as it
was a test like hey you have to prove
that you're your the the your the actual
machine the God we worship but to do
that you have to destroy kind of like an
allegory for rapture you know for for
this guy who's basically an
insurrectionist more-or-less who's
literally trying to destroy like our
entire religious component which is kind
of interesting here now something else
that goes on this is something I want to
kind of point to you and Joshua Williams
it is gonna be very ambiguous about this
we transition over to another place in
the ghost sector and we're basically met
with like black fire now this is where
things get kind of murky right because
when it comes to like DC because when it
comes to really DC rebirth because DC
rebirth is blending a lot of things that
happened before the new 52 you with
things that happen after new 52
characters like [ __ ] Mandor like black
fire she's appeared in both sheba
appeared before DC rebooted and after DC
rebooted and so oftentimes we really end
up looking two stories in particular or
lines and stories things that characters
say in order to tell us like which
version of the character it is and
William plays it very very ambiguous
here because really like core Manor
doesn't doesn't specify either way but
there are like when it comes to like the
original
never here - from back in the day she
was basically like a bad omen for the
people of Tamra right it's really kind
of her Tamra it's really kind of how it
was perceived on the day she was born
you had it was called the Citadel Empire
which was like this fascist Empire
they're basically like invaded the West
City and invaded like Tamra and in turn
killed like 3,000 people not only that
she didn't really have the ability to
enter like absorb ultraviolet rays the
way that like Tamra normally did and so
because of that she was kind of
considered to be like a false queen like
if she had been appointed to the to the
queen ship she would have been like not
really a Tamra and it's how people
viewed her like she's bad omen and she
can't really do what everybody else can
and so she's not really not really good
enough to lead their people on the other
side of the equation Starfire basically
was and so there was kind of a rivalry
there was actually a lot of hatred that
really existed between the two of them
now if you go into the new 52 things are
a little bit different what you had was
a race it was a group called the blight
now the blight was basically like this
sort of race for those guys coming from
Star Trek thing of the blight is like
the Borg to a degree the differences of
the blight were continually basically
breaking down like they were literally
dying and they were pursuing the secrets
of immortality that basically brought
them in a conflict it really kind of
brought them across the path of the
tamarins and literally like that LEDs
like Cory Anne are more or less being
sold or at least it was believed that
she was sold by black fire but the fact
remains that like there was cut there
was on both sides of the equation there
was animosity between the two sisters
now in Red Hood in the outlaws where a
lot of that stuff was explained when it
came to starve Starfire in the new 52
when it came to like you know core
Mandor her sister and and so on and so
forth a lot of that was kind of resolved
and the two of them basically went back
to being friends or you know kind of you
know acknowledged and you know Coriana
forgave her sister you know all I kind
of good stuff
in this scenario like they're still
hatred they're they're still basically
enemies like it's the the pre new 52
version of core Manor but again it's not
necessarily specified but basically like
Rome Anders filling her lot in with
Darkseid and so that's why why things
kind of get crazy because it's like
Darkseid basically promises her rule
over over Tamron if like the two of them
how I you know allied with each other
now not only that one of the things we
actually find out here is that because
this race worships cyborg that what they
basically done is created a mother box
and it's kind of a big thing because her
mother boxes allow like travel around
the multiverse and really like it could
lead to an escape if they create a
successfully create a mother box and
they open a boom tube they could in turn
like teleport outside of the go sucker
and who knows what would happen after
that because we don't know if this race
would basically start spreading the
gospel it's like literally turn like the
universe into a holy war
we really we don't really know if that's
exactly what would happen and there's a
fear that it would and so those who are
confined within the ghost sector because
they're supposed to be here technically
speaking they're not really supposed to
be allowed to leave and so what we end
up doing is kind of transitioning back
over to dark side and Blackfyre and
literally what dark side basically says
here is that he set in motion a kind of
failsafe should the time ever come when
like apocalypse is destroyed and so what
this plan is we don't really know
specifically at least not into a cyborg
figures it out and with cyborg basically
like like putting his mother box to task
putting his mind a task trying to figure
out what's going on with Darkseid at the
same time you know everything's kind of
popping off he basically realizes what
Darkseid intends to do is to create a
new apocalypse now we don't know why
Darkseid wants to create a new
apocalypse because as far as we're aware
unless it was destroyed during godhead
apocalypse is still there we know that
New Genesis was destroyed during Godhead
and then a new version of New Genesis
was built but like as far as I'm aware
of pocalypse is still around like the
planets still exists there's no reason
to believe apocalypse is gone which
really begs the question why is Darkseid
building a new one like why is he making
a new planet and that's why things are
kind of crazy is because then at that
point that with Darkseid you know going
down into this giant water pit whatever
it happens to be and then retrieving
something what he basically ends up
doing is showing something called the
other box not a mother box but an other
box a device created by dark Sider at
least planned by Darkseid for quite some
time and now he's finally able to
retrieve it and that's the truth of why
the ghost sector exists the ghost sector
exists because of the fact that at some
point along the line Darkseid put this
plan in motion and the Cullens somehow
became aware of it and that's why I like
a lot of these worlds were essentially
bottled up by them as long as they were
bottled up and kept hidden Darkseid
could not find them and then once all
those worlds were freed the guardians of
the universe immediately activists said
whoa whoa whoa if these worlds are freed
and they're thrown out into the universe
Darkseid exists he's back now he's gonna
be able to easily track down all these
different artifacts and basically like
recreate apocalypse and so we're going
to basically confine all these worlds
into the ghost sector we're gonna put a
giant maelstrom around them so nothing
gets in nothing gets out we're gonna put
green lanterns around it to garden and
the morgue initially going to keep all
these different things from safekeeping
so the dark side can one never rise back
to his full level of power and two
cannot recreate apocalypse and so it's
kind of a crazy scenario because he's
basically been able to pull that off now
in issue number six it's explained like
we basically get an explanation for why
but issue number six is not part of the
story so
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
Oh